hey everyone welcome to hd power saver
um battery saver episode number four in
this one i'll be showing you guys a
little something with my screencasting
software about how you can save battery
life using the actual built-in windows
um power management software basically
what i'm going to show you is that you
can change the windows power options how
it actually uses power it dims the
screen automatically turns down the cpu
the graphics off automatically
and it won't change the resolution of
your screen which i'll show you later
but it definitely is
by far the easiest way to change the um
how much how long your computer can
actually last on battery so i'm go ahead
and watch the software part which is
going to come up right after this and
that's it so yeah enjoy
all right guys windows power options is
a really really really simple and easy
way to to change and tone down how much
battery you're using if you're trying to
max out your battery which is what this
whole video series is about so what
you're going to want to do right here
i'm actually i don't have my battery in
right now which is pretty intense i just
have it plugged in and it's um it's
running off the power so i just left
click on it once
and windows vista you'll be able to
select the power plan i'm in high
performance mode now if i were to take
the cord out and just have battery it's
going to say this favors performance but
you will you'll be sacrificing quite a
bit of battery life on this plan
power saver is what your computer is
balanced is actually what your computer
is set on by default you're not getting
the most performance out of your desktop
replacement if you have it on balance
so i leave mine on this on high
replacement on sorry high performance
when mine's sitting at my desk doing my
work playing games etc power saver is
the mode you want to put it in that will
automatically dim your screen turn down
pretty much everything tone down your
cpu and just let you do the core basics
of what you're doing listening to music
checking an email just doing some basic
skype calls or whatever so i leave mine
on high performance mode now if you're
working with windows xp
there is a quite different way to do
this first of all you want to go to your
control panel which you can also find in
the start menu and in windows xp i'm
remembering off the top of my head here
let's wait for the control panel open
okay i'm going to go to
see here it should be under power
options this will not work on a desktop
a desktop automatically uses the max
amount of power it's high performance
etc
but because you're not trying to save
battery if you have a laptop you'll have
a power options button double click on
the power options button and there are
your power plans you just set which one
you want it'll even have a little dial
here also since i bought an hp pavilion
if i show additional plans there's hp
recommended playing which is kind of
like the balance plan you see here
so that is episode number four on power
plans how to um save your battery and
hopefully watch this in hd so you can
see everything clearly and that is
basically it so if you have any alright
i hope you found that last tutorial
helpful on your battery saving tips my
eight cell laptop battery here
basically what you're going to do
is
change the change the power saver
options when you're in windows vista
if you have any other questions or you
want me to do another tutorial like i
said just leave a subscribe to my page
and
that button over there or if you're
watching in hd it's down there and
subscribe to my page send me a message
hit me up i'll do whatever i can and
answer your question so um thanks for
watching and more episodes to come peace